[MUSIC PLAYING]
ETANA: How you doing?
You all right?
If you feel all right,
let me hear you say yeah!
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
[MUSIC - ETANA, "JAH CHARIOT"]
ETANA: You love reggae music?
[MUSIC - ETANA, "REGGAE"]
ETANA: And oftentimes
when you hear this,
the ladies are moving
the waistline like that.
Yeah.
The men are usually--
[MUSIC - ETANA, "REGGAE"]
[MUSIC - ETANA, "MOCKING BIRD"]
ETANA: Yeah!
A lot of people like to talk.
That's what they do.
Every day.
And you know what?
[MUSIC - ETANA, "PEOPLE TALK"]
ETANA: You still feel good?
Say yeah!
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
ETANA: Now, this next song is
a tribute to the great Gregory
Isaacs.
If you don't know him, he's
like a huge reggae icon
that's loved all over the world.
And do the rock that
I taught you earlier.
Let's go.
[MUSIC - ETANA]
ETANA: Now, this
next song-- thank
you-- is from the fourth
album coming out-- well,
upcoming album that's being
released tomorrow, on the 28th.
It's called Love Song.
It's about unconditional love,
meaning loving that person
regardless of the things
they do, say, look like, eat,
whatever.
Just loving them
unconditionally.
Ready?
[MUSIC - ETANA, "LOVE SONG"]
ETANA: Now, this one
is from an album that
was released already, but
it's a real love song.
A real one.
[MUSIC ETANA FT.
ALBOROSI, "BLESSING"]
ETANA: Now, this one
is called "Wifey,"
and it's for the ladies
who know they bad,
whether they have
the ring or not.
Ready?
[MUSIC - ETANA, "WIFEY"]
ETANA: I'm anointed from
the crown on my head
to the soles of my feet.
Fear no one.
I love you unconditionally,
no matter what
you believe in, what
you wear, what you eat,
where you stay, where you
live, where you sleep.
I just love you as a person.
And when I look at the world,
wherever I go across the world,
I want everyone in the world
to look at me as a person.
Unconditional love from
my heart to all of you.
One perfect love.
[MUSIC ETANA, "I AM NOT AFRAID"]
ETANA: I'm not afraid
of what I look like.
I'm not afraid of where I live.
I'm not afraid to tell
you where I'm from.
I'm not afraid of being me.
I'm not afraid of being happy.
Or what they call
so-called embarrassed.
Doesn't bother me.
Cause peoples' negative opinion
of me is none of my business.
I have no fear.
Period.
And so me--
[MUSIC ETANA, "I AM NOT AFRAID"]
FEMALE SPEAKER: So welcome.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How are you?
ETANA: I'm grateful and happy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Your album comes out in what,
like, less than eight hours?
ETANA: I know, right?
I'm so excited, I can't--
I just can't wait.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, we're
thrilled to have you here.
And I've got as many questions
as you can sit through,
so you just tell me.
Just want to start off,
for people that may not
be familiar with
you, do you just
want to tell them a
little bit about yourself,
and your background, and
how you got into music?
ETANA: Well, I'm from
Kingston, Jamaica,
in a small town
called August Town.
And when you say August
Town, a lot of people go, oh.
You know?
Because it used to be a happy
place, but I guess politics,
turf war, violence has
turned it into someplace
that people shy
away from, you know?
I started reggae
like, probably 2005,
I was a backup singer for a
male artist called Richie Spice.
And from then, I remember
one day he got really ill,
and they wanted to
kind of like, you
know, kill some of the
time, the performance time.
So they were like, go.
Sing.
Sing some songs.
And I had to kind of
come up with stuff
to sing for 15 minutes.
Well, that's all I could do is
15 minutes, because I didn't
have anything
rehearsed, or anything.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
What did you sing?
ETANA: I did Lauren Hill songs.
I did "Rastaman
Chant." [SINGING]
"I hear the sound of
a Rasta man sing."
You know, stuff like that.
And ever since that day, it
was like a thing for me, now.
Like I had to go and
open for him every night.
And people kept
asking who I was,
and that's where it started.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
how old were you then?
ETANA: Wow.
Like--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Not
to call you out, but--
ETANA: I was probably like, 22.
21.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And were
you going by Etana, then?
So it--
ETANA: No.
It was just Shauna.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
ETANA: I changed it later.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Tell people about the
origin of your name, Etana.
ETANA: Shauna means pretty,
as the given name, right?
But I feel like women are
beautiful all over the world,
but we don't always remember
how powerful we are.
And so I said I
wanted a name that
would remind every woman
when they see the name,
they know, OK,
that applies to me.
I'm strong, I'm powerful.
I can do this.
And so I found the name
Etana, in Swahili it
means the strong one-- and I
said OK, well, that's the name.
So every time they--
women see the name Etana,
know it applies to all of you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I like that.
So when you were
growing up in Jamaica,
who were some of your,
like, biggest influences?
The people that inspired you
the most to get into music?
ETANA: Wow.
A lot of people.
My mom used to listen to
country music every Sunday.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Really?
ETANA: Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Like,
American country music?
ETANA: Country music.
Country country.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Like Billy
Ray Cyrus country country,
or like--
ETANA: Like Tammy
Wynette country,
like Dolly Parton country.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
Yes.
ETANA: And then as I grew
up, I would listen to like,
Bob Marley, Sizzla Kalonji.
Even Air Supply, I was like,
a big fan of Air Supply music,
all the way up to now.
Whitney Houston, Mariah
Carey, and Stevie Wonder.
A broad, you know,
range of people.
Of course Bob Marley, Bob
Marley, Bob Marley, Bob Marley.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
you moved to the US
with your family at a
relatively young age,
and you went to
school to be a nurse.
ETANA: Right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
how did you transition
from wanting to be a nurse
to decide that you wanted
to pursue singing as a career?
ETANA: Well, I always
used to love singing,
I just never thought
that I would be a singer.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: You know?
And I remember being
in psychology class,
and I was so bored every
day, because it sounded
like another language
altogether, and I was bored.
And so I would write poetry
in the class, you know?
And I was talking to
a friend of mine who--
he lives on South Beach,
and I said, you know what?
I'm just so tired of coming
from school, going to work,
doing the same thing.
Sending a fax, emails,
turning lights on and off.
It's boring, you know?
And he, said, well
you could sing.
And there is a guy
looking for a black girl
to join for a girl group.
So maybe I should do your
makeup, take you down there,
and, you know, you
do the audition.
And I said OK, well, I
don't have anything to lose,
and I went down there, and
I got in on the same day,
surprisingly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Nice.
So you were in this girl
group for a little while.
ETANA: Like about two years.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
It wasn't really--
wasn't really your thing?
ETANA: Well, I had
fun with the girls.
I liked the shopping part.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
ETANA: And I loved the fact
that we lived in one house.
That we had to do
choreography together.
But I hated the fact that we had
to work out seven days a week,
eat nothing but seaweed
and salmon, or cereal.
And water, no juice,
no cakes, no nothing.
You know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: No jerk chicken?
ETANA: No jerk chicken.
Forget that, you know?
And the main thing was that
I couldn't express myself
the way I wanted to.
Like, I couldn't write any song.
You had to sing what was
given, wear what was given.
I'm talking about
shoes, and everything.
You couldn't do your
hair without them
approving your look.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Very packaged.
Like, it was like the boy bands?
ETANA: We had to just
fit in all the time.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Like
N*Sync, Britney Spears era?
ETANA: Yeah.
Like lingerie,
stiletto heel wearing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, and
you didn't like that?
ETANA: No, because I remember
doing choreography one day,
and the camera guy had the
camera so low-- like, he had it
in this angle, looking up at
me, and I had on thong lingerie,
see through, with
stiletto heels.
And I have to do
this choreography
where I have to
turn to the side.
You know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: A
little grinding.
ETANA: I was like, no.
OK?
No.
And I--
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's invasive.
ETANA: Very.
And I said, you know what?
Yeah, I look really good.
You're beautiful.
Like, this is just wicked.
And for some, it's like
chance of a lifetime.
You don't just walk off.
You know?
And I decided after a while
that it wasn't for me.
And they cried, and they
cried, and they screamed,
and we fought.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Well, that must have
made you feel good,
though, that--
ETANA: No.
FEMALE SPEAKER: They
valued that much
that they were gonna
cry, and scream,
and fight for you to be there.
ETANA: Well, yeah.
I mean, yeah, but then I
still-- I even thought that we
could've-- we write.
We wanted to sing what
we wanted to sing.
We were never even
given that chance.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: You know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, let's
talk about happier times.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Let's talk about
your fourth problem, I Rise,
which, again, comes
out in less than a day.
Where did you write
and record that,
and what was the
inspiration for this album,
as opposed to some
of your older albums,
and what was that like for you?
ETANA: Well, the album was
recorded in Jamaica, with,
like, the-- well, one of
the top produces, if not
the top producer.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, don't
sell yourself short.
Don't sell yourself short.
ETANA: If not the top
producer in Jamaica right now.
He's been around for years.
Did songs with some of the best
rock stars that you may know.
And reggae, too, as well.
Clive Hunt is a genius,
and if you've ever watched,
like, the mad scientist
movies and see how they act,
that's just Clive.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: But he's smart, you know?
And I wanted the
music to sound live.
I wanted it to be big.
I wanted everything about
this album to be massive.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So it this that-- I know you
recorded your previous album
at the Tuff Gong
Studios in Jamaica.
Was this at the same one?
ETANA: No.
We did this album in
Clive Hunt's space,
and at a small studio called
Barbed Wire Music Studio.
He's a young producer
too, as well,
of a band called
[INAUDIBLE] in Jamaica.
A very gifted,
seriously gifted--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Right on.
So for the people that aren't
necessarily familiar with Tuff
Gong, it was started by The
Wailers back in the 1960s,
and it produced a lot of
really well known songs,
like "Redemption Song--"
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: "Stir It Up."
ETANA: All of the
Bob Marley songs.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
All the good ones.
ETANA: Yeah.
All of them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So what was it like recording
and working in that space?
Did you--
ETANA: I remember
the first time when
I had to sing in that
studio, and there
was a guy in the studio--
a man-- older Chinese man.
I forgot his name, but he
never comes out of the studio.
He would be the one that would
always take care of Bob Marley,
take care of the
instruments in the studio.
He flew from China just to
be-- or from Japan, I'm sorry.
Flew from Japan to be
where Bob Marley was.
And up to this day,
he's still there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Lives there?
ETANA: He lives in the studio.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wow.
ETANA: He never comes out.
And that day when I was
singing, he came out,
and everybody was
like-- you know?
FEMALE SPEAKER:
You unearthed him.
ETANA: Like, you're out?
Oh my god, you know?
And everybody was
like, he's out.
He's out.
But it was very, very
warm to see him come out
and help the musicians,
to make sure--
just like he did
for Bob Marley--
to make sure the instruments and
everything was sounding great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
you recently came off
of the the Jamrock Cruise?
Jam to--
ETANA: Now, that--
the Jamrock Cruise.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Jamrock Cruise.
Yeah.
ETANA: That was amazing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Which is
headed by Damian Marley?
ETANA: Right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So what was
your experience with the Marleys
before then, and how was
that cruise, and what
did they try to-- did they
have any advice for you,
in terms of trying to break
through in America with reggae?
ETANA: No, we never
spoke like that.
I think every time
that we met, we
were either rehearsing
or recording.
You know, because I did some
recording sessions with Stephen
Marley, and Jr. Gong,
he was always serious.
I see him sulking,
like, you know?
Always very serious.
But the idea of the
cruise was amazing,
because the cruise sold
out in three weeks.
Like, they put it up, and
it was down in a month.
And I think they're going to
have to get a bigger ship.
FEMALE SPEAKER: A bigger boat?
ETANA: They're going to have
to get a bigger one next year.
And they're probably
going to have to have two,
because even then people
were on Facebook saying,
does anybody have any tickets?
Does anybody have any tickets?
Because it was
completely sold out.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's incredible.
ETANA: It's amazing.
And one of the things
that I admired the most
is that when you
go to a festival,
right, there's this
big barrier, and there
are thousands of people way
back there-- behind the barrier,
though.
On the cruise, everyone
is like, right there.
And you take the shuttle, and
people are in the bus saying,
can we take a picture?
Because we're
sharing the shuttle
with the people on the ship.
We walk around on the ship, we
eat next to our fans, you know?
It's cool.
Really cool.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's very nice.
So, why do you think
that reggae hasn't really
caught on in the US
the same way that it
is in other parts of the world?
Because I mean, obviously
when Bob Marley was around,
it eventually came
to the US after it
had exposure in Europe.
But since then, there really
hasn't been much of a,
I guess, popular reggae
culture in the US.
So why do you think that's
kind of died down, and made
it more difficult
for reggae to be
a more prominent
genre over here?
ETANA: Well, for
some reason I think
that reggae is being shut
off mainstream radio.
Well, it has been shut off
mainstream radio, period.
But there's this movement
that's-- well, for the past,
I don't know, three, four years,
that you have American bands
who have sold out
vanues across the US.
I think they have it
so locked down now
that they're actually moving
from the US to Europe.
So they're taking the
reggae from here to Europe.
Usually it's Europe
to America, right?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: But the only thing is
that those bands are not--
most of them, they're
straight Americans,
and not Jamaican bands.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The
blue eyed reggae.
ETANA: Yeah.
So I think-- no, but
it's not for everybody.
Like, OK, what I mean by that
is if you tour a lot in the US,
you will see the same people who
support the American bands come
out to support your show.
Because I've seen it.
And they come out
in the numbers.
But you have to tour
for them to see you,
because you're not
on mainstream radio.
So they don't know.
Right?
And it may be difficult
for Jamaican bands
to tour, because of visa,
finances, or whatever it is.
But nobody said
it should be easy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: So when I
do it, I go hard.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
All right.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I was
speaking with your drummer
earlier before the
show, and we were
talking about the differences
between reggae music
in Jamaica, and what's
successful here in the US.
And with reggae, very
much so about the message,
and commenting on the
culture and politics,
and it's more of like, a call
to action than it is in the US,
where it's a lot
more materialistic.
It's a little bit more vain,
it's a little bit more vapid.
ETANA: Yeah.
You know, it's interesting that
he said as well that in Jamaica
now with reggae
artists, he feels
like those American
ideals in music
have kind of been imposed
upon the music and reggae,
so that a lot of
artists are having
to kind of stray from the
roots of the reggae message,
and incorporate these US
ideals into their songs
in order to try
to be successful.
So how do you--
well, first of all,
have you found it difficult to
stay true to your core values?
ETANA: No.
FEMALE SPEAKER: No.
All right.
ETANA: No, but you know what?
I feel that if you're
true and real to yourself,
then people will see
that, and they'll
gravitate to your realness.
You.
You know?
But I think if
you try to put on,
that's when people are like
yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever.
We've seen this before.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: I just feel
like I'm being myself,
and it's working for me.
And I don't know how
to be anything else.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
That's good.
That's wonderful.
So in that same vein,
in terms of reggae
and Jamaican music in
general kind of drawing
attention to different issues,
political, social, cultural,
what do you think is
the issue in Jamaica
right now that really
deserves the most attention?
ETANA: Education.
And, yeah.
Education.
That's it.
I think it deserves the most
attention because people
tend to overlook
the little ones.
Oh, they don't matter.
They don't have a voice.
They can't speak.
You know, they do what
we say do kind of thing.
Because Caribbean
parents are like that.
You do what I say.
Shut up.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: Kind of thing, you know?
But I think that it's time
that we listen and invest
a lot more in
education in Jamaica.
A lot of Caribbean
countries, they
have free education
because they're still
under the British rule,
or the French, you know?
But Jamaica somewhat
is still, but not when
it comes to free education.
So you have a lot of
children who stay home
because of poverty, you know?
And I think it doesn't
do much for the economy,
it doesn't do much for
the whole country itself.
It's wrong to have
them kids sit there,
not know how to read
and write, and grow up
doing things that
society don't accept.
Or even put other people
in fear because they're
trying to survive the
best way they know how.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you've been in the US--
so you live in Florida now?
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How long
have you been in the US for?
ETANA: Well, about
three years now.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Three years.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
is there something
in particular in the
US that you kind of
think is an issue that
people are ignoring,
musicians are ignoring,
that they could speak out
against in the same way
that reggae artists do?
I know that's a
tough kind of like--
ETANA: Well, if you
look at hip hop,
you know, it's kind of like they
rap about what they see, right?
I don't think there's much that
they can do to change that.
It just is what it is.
And when you-- I'm not sure
that they could do anything
about it, really.
Because if they stop rapping
about, you know, the B-I-T-C-H,
and if the girls stop showing
themselves in the videos,
do you think--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Money and cars.
ETANA: Yeah.
Do you think that people
would still pay attention?
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Well, you know, we
were talking about this earlier,
about how someone like Jay Z
could be that person.
I mean, this is putting--
ETANA: To make the change?
FEMALE SPEAKER: To
make the change.
You know, someone that's
that big in American culture,
to try to step up
and make that change,
and really call attention
to things that people aren't
seeing or doing, or--
ETANA: Well, maybe.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Maybe it's tough.
ETANA: Because I've seen
people like Common and Mos Def,
and they're not into that
stuff, but they're not
as popular as the person who
may do the opposite, you know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
it's tough.
It's a lot of-- you have to
make choices, and whether or not
you want to be you and speak
to the things that you value,
or if you're, you
know, OK with letting
some of that go in
order to achieve
a different kind of fame.
ETANA: Well, how I see it
is that I wonder when they
do these things, rap
about these things,
or behave a certain way in
the media, how do they expect,
or how-- I'm wondering if their
children, like if they have
kids, if they get to watch
their mom or dad do that on TV,
and then how do they raise
them in the right way,
to say OK, well, we're
just doing that for show.
Like, it's not real.
We don't really do that.
You know, I'm wondering
how they deal with it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How
they, like, instill
values in them that are--
ETANA: That are right and true.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So sticking
with the reggae theme,
and the difference
between things in the US
and there-- I mean,
you're arguably,
like, one of the most notable
female reggae artists,
you know, today.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
for a long time now.
ETANA: Yeah.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You know, the
most visible, prominent, lovely
reggae artist.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Was
it difficult for you
to find your footing in a genre
that's predominately male?
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
ETANA: Of course.
Like, you would sometimes--
there was a time when females
were on the bill for the
show, and they would show up,
and they kind of
shoved them off.
And, oh, it's not your time yet.
And then when they call them
on, like sometimes a male
will come on the stage
and, yeah, my time
now, and grab the mic
and start singing.
So they didn't, you know,
like, a fair chance to perform.
So what we did at 5th
Element at the time
is they had a man
walk me up on stage.
A man would block the
stage on both ends.
Nobody was able to walk
up on my stage ever,
and they would have a
man walk me off stage,
walk my guitar on, walk
my guitar off, you know?
Kind of teach them
how to treat me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: And that's what I did.
I taught them how to treat me.
And so I feel like I still
have-- we still have a long way
to go, because women in
general all over the world,
sometimes we're not looked upon
as the same or equal to a man.
So we're at times paid
less, given awkward jobs,
and stuff like that,
even though we're
qualified to do-- over
qualified, sometimes,
to do what the man might do.
And it's the same
thing with reggae.
And so I think we
still have a long way
to go, but as far as
respect and billing
me as a headliner and stuff
like, I don't have any issues.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Well, I think we can
all appreciate that.
I mean, the image that
you're putting forth,
even just in the name that
you chose, and the song
Strong Jamaican Woman
from your new album,
it's really encouraging to
hear that kind of stuff.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
There's a lot of female
artists out there
who speak about
being a woman, but I
feel like you're one of the more
honest and heartfelt artists
out there that are doing that.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I
think it's wonderful.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you
consider yourself a role model?
Is that important to you?
ETANA: Well, you know, I just
live my life the best way
I know I can.
You know?
And I like to sleep well
when I do go to sleep.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: So I try my best
to do good wherever I go,
and live my life in such a way
that I create better tomorrows.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: You know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
feel like that's
a very intimidating title for
a lot of female musicians,
and-- well, moreso
female than male,
to be seen as a role model.
Because it puts a lot
of pressure on you
in terms of if you
make a misstep, and--
ETANA: Yeah.
At times, like, if
something goes wrong,
and you feel like
yelling or cussing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: You know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Uh-huh.
ETANA: Like, I kind
of have to hold it, go
inside somewhere where
there's just me and my manager
or somebody, and then
scream, you know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: Because then if
I do, then other people
look at me like,
Etana said that.
You know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
hard to have a filter.
ETANA: Yeah.
So I kind of-- I don't
display it that much.
And I don't put myself in
positions where I know.
And if something
arise, I deal with it
with as much
diplomacy as possible.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So how do you stay calm?
How do you stay positive?
ETANA: I just stay laughing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
ETANA: I just laugh
at everything.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You got
a lot of good jokes?
ETANA: I just laugh
at everything.
Seriously, I'm always laughing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well,
we need to hang out
more often, then, so
that I can do that, too.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, switching
gears just a little bit here,
getting towards
the end, I wanted
to ask you about
your line of jewelry,
and your skirts, and
your organic soaps.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Are you wearing
any of your line right now?
ETANA: Well, let me see.
No.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What?
How could you come here without
wearing your own jewelry?
ETANA: You know what?
I had them on for the past
three shows that we did,
and for some reason
today I didn't.
I didn't.
I don't know why.
But people are always asking me,
where did you get that skirt?
Where did you get that earring?
Where did you get, you
know, that bracelet?
And I figured-- and on
Facebook people say,
OK, don't tell me where
you got that skirt, tell me
where you got the fabric.
Or tell me who made it, so I
can have them make it, you know?
So I decided I'm just
going to have these stuff,
make these stuff, and have
them available for people
who want to purchase these.
But I have young
girls who may find
it hard to find jobs
in Jamaica, right?
Seamstresses.
Very talented.
And, you know, I
use the skirt line
as a job opportunity for them.
So it's like woman
helping woman.
So they make the skirts, and
women outside buy the skirts.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's wonderful.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I like that
you keep it at home like that.
That's very, very admirable.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
But next time, bring some of
those things here so we can--
ETANA: The jewelry, too.
The soaps, too.
Same thing, like, the
girls make the jewelry.
Sometimes I do the jewelry
when I do have my free time.
Because I love to paint, and
so I have hand painted jewelry.
My husband, too.
Like, we all get
involved, you know?
It's a family thing.
It's love, and sharing,
and caring, and everything.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And you
have two young children.
So they help out
with that as well?
ETANA: Well-- too young.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Are they young?
They're not old?
ETANA: No, they're not
old, but, you know,
my daughter is only two.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: And my son is 13.
He doesn't care
about that stuff.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Finger painting.
She can finger paint, right?
ETANA: He's like, he's
not into that stuff.
He's just like,
Mom, just tell me
how to do this business stuff,
and I'll try to help you out.
But I'm not gonna paint.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
I'll keep the books.
ETANA: Yeah.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Cool.
So just to wrap it up, I just
have a couple of fun questions.
So I work for Songza
within Google,
which I mentioned to you
when we spoke earlier,
but we are music
streaming, and we
do a lot of curated playlists.
And so we have
some fun questions
that we like to ask artists.
ETANA: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I've
tried to pare them down
to the less risque ones.
So I just have a couple here,
so what was the first tape, CD,
or vinyl that you
bought, and why?
[HUMMING]
ETANA: I still remember that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Mine was Paula
Abdul, Forever Your Girl,
if that makes you feel better.
ETANA: No, I think
it was instrumental.
Like, all instrument.
Like jazz.
I forgot the name of the artist.
He blows the flute.
I forgot the name of the artist,
but that was the first CD
that I actually
bought for myself.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You're buying
instrumentals, the first CD?
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wow.
ETANA: Isn't that weird?
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's-- yeah.
You were clearly
more mature than I
was when I was buying music.
What was the first
concert that you went to?
ETANA: There was a concert with
[INAUDIBLE] and Sizzla Kalonji.
I actually snuck
into that club, too.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah?
ETANA: Yeah.
I put on a lot of makeup,
I made my lips really red,
and I remember wearing this wig
that was really long down here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
you pulled it off?
ETANA: And I pulled it off.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
ETANA: I was so
happy when I got in.
Yeah, it was cool.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Was that in
Jamaica, or was that in the US?
ETANA: No, that was in Miami.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
Oh, those clubs are hard to
get into when you're young.
ETANA: I pulled it off.
I pulled it off.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Appreciate you.
ETANA: I lied so hard.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Show a little leg.
It's fine.
ETANA: I think-- my
clothes were so short.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Uh-huh.
ETANA: I remember I had on
this really short skirt,
looking really cute.
So I know.
But you know, I tried to
look as old as possible.
They know.
I think he must have figured it
out, because I was so skinny.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right on.
So when you were a
teenager, assuming you
were as angsty as most
teenagers are growing up--
ETANA: Yeah?
FEMALE SPEAKER:
What song, or what
album would you play to
piss off your parents?
ETANA: Lady Saw.
I would put in a Lady Saw
CD, or something like that.
Like, (SINGING) "If the
man live--" And you know.
My mom would be
like, turn it off.
No.
Turn it off.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Mine was Lil
Kim, so I got a little dirtier.
But that's great.
ETANA: Oh, no.
Trust me, if you listen to
that song, the raw version,
your mom would tell you
to turn it off, too.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah?
We have to send me that.
I still like to piss off
my parents, so-- all right,
so let's see.
So obviously you did some covers
during your set, which I loved.
You did Is This Love, you
did the Dawn Penn song.
ETANA: No, No, No.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: I love doing that song.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you
have any other songs
that you really enjoy
covering when you're live?
Like, what's your favorite?
Or were those your favorite?
[SINGING]
ETANA: When I did that song,
and I listened back to it,
I said, oh my god.
You know?
But I'm actually
happy that I asked
Marcia Griffiths about
doing that song over.
And she'd say, Etana, if
them ask you to do 10, do 10.
You know?
She was like, do it.
Do it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ETANA: You know?
But I was a little bit
nervous, because that's
Marcia Griffiths.
That's like, the
queen of reggae.
When you hear her songs
play all over the world,
you know, people
kind of lose it.
So in my mind,
I'm like, OK, am I
going to make this good enough,
you know, everybody out there?
And when I heard it back,
and heard all the comments,
I figured, OK.
I got it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
sure you did it justice.
ETANA: Yeah.
It was wicked.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
Last one, and then we'll
see if anybody else
has any questions for you.
What's your guilty
pleasure song?
Like, what do you sing to
yourself in the mirror?
Like, dancing in your underwear.
ETANA: Let me see.
I have a couple.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Give them all to us.
ETANA: There's a
song called Refill.
(SINGING) Can I get a refill?
I'm not good with names at all.
Yeah, Elle.
I like--
ETANA: There you
go, [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, Refill.
I love Elle, you know?
And there's another
one that she did,
called I Said I Only
Want To Give It To You.
Yeah, that song is wicked.
And so, you know.
ETANA: Do the reggae rump, too.
ETANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
All right.
Well, does anyone else have any
questions for the lovely Etana?
I can't see anything out
there, but if you do,
stand up, wave your hand around.
Hoot and holler.
No?
ETANA: Shy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Shy.
They're too shy.
All right.
Well, thank you so much, Etana.
ETANA: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
This was wonderful.
ETANA: And thanks to
everyone for being here.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And go
out and buy the album.
It's out tonight.
ETANA: I Rise.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I Rise.
Go get it.
ETANA: I can't wait to
have it on my iPhone.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
You mean your Droid,
because we're at Google.
ETANA: Oh, yeah.
That's right.
My Droid.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Your Droid.
ETANA: Well, you know what?
That would be my husband, then.
Because he doesn't
like iPhone at all.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's good.
We appreciate that.
All right, lady.
Thank you again so much.
ETANA: Thanks to everyone.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.